the national debt crosses the 20
trillion dollar mark it was big news
when our national debt passed the 20
trillion dollar bond
what's less understood is exactly why
having such a massive debt as a bad
thing the sheer size of the existing
debt is deeply worrying to economist on
both the left and the right to agree
that when debt reaches 90% of GDP it
means painfully slow economic growth
creating what's called a debt overhang a
group of progressive economist
affiliated with the University of
Massachusetts predicted in 2013 that a
debt burden at that level would result
in an annual growth rate of just 2.2
percent which means economic stagnation
and anemic job growth so when will our
debt load cross the 90% threshold it's
actually been at more than 100 percent
of GDP for years now periods of slow
growth associated with that overhangs
almost always lasts more than a decade
and sometimes stretch out over a quarter
century that means that in 25 years the
overall economy will be about 75 percent
the size of would have been if the
government had only gotten the debt in
check countries like New Zealand Canada
and Germany have demonstrated that when
governments reduce debt good things
happen u.s. spending by contrast has
been above 20% of GDP for years which is
well above the historical average
no wonder the Congressional Budget
Office predicts that the economy will
grow less than 2% annually over the next
decade
compare that to growth rates of more
than 3% for much of the post-world War
two period Barack Obama and George W
Bush were leaders who lacked the
integrity to do what's best for the
country by keeping spending and dead in
line President Donald Trump Ossa shows
no interest in explaining to the public
how runaway debt chokes off the future
and that's a failure which we'll all be
paying for for a very long time to come
dead
[Music]
I am the king of debt